البوابه الخارجيه او الاماميه لمحكمه
ميامي فعلا هو وصل موكب ترامب وصل الان
متابع هذا الصور لوصول موكب ترامب يبدو
بانها البوابه الخارجيه لمحكمه ميامي
وهناك سياره شرطه طبعا تؤمن هذا الموكب
ولحظه وصوله هناك مجموعه من الامنيين
توجهوا في بعض او للقيام ببعض الاجراءات
ومن ثم سيدخل وبدات السيارات تتوجه الى
داخل محيط المحكمه حيث يتواجد عدد كبير
وكان حدثنا منذ قليل مراسله العربيه
المتواجد هناك حسين الطوط متواجد داخل
محيط المحكمه وحدثنا عن حضور اعلامي كبير
وعن متابعه اعلاميه كبيره جدا لحيثيات
اولا حيثيات البدء بالحديث عن هذا الملف
وكذلك حتى التحقيقات والمتابعه
التصريحات اتت من الجمهوريين كما كذلك من
الديمقراطيين ولكن كان ملفت في هذه
الساعات الاخيره
صمت الجمهوريين او على الاقل حتى ان لم
يتقدموا بالدعم والتشجيع ومحاوله مؤازره
الرئيس هناك من صمت ولم يعلق على خاصه
لائحه الاتهامات التي تتعلق بالامن القومي
الامريكي نتحدث عن الاسلحه النوويه
الامريكيه نتحدث عن التمركز العسكري حال
الهجوم الخارجي نتحدث كذلك عن بعض الاسرار
الخاصه ببعض الدول كايران والصين والعديد
من الملفات الاخرى وخاصه المعلومات الاخرى
التي صنفت حساسه وسريه وبعضها صنف كذلك
سري للغايه لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قنات نا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر
الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات